most people most Champions do not have
something that you do not have they lack
something that you have or a champion in
the Physical Realm a lot of times it's
they don't have an off switch they just
keep going and so to the same degree you
probably do things every single day that
you should not be doing and so what I
want to introduce to you is a concept of
the anti-routine as the most productive
routine that is humanly possible for you
to accomplish what you want number one
is obviously just shifting the
perspective of I need to do more things
and I need to add more things to my
routine when in fact you need to stop
doing things that you're currently doing
all that remains is the work to be done
priorities mean two things cannot be
equally important when you work on
something if I spend 30 minutes on both
things and I say this one's more
important than this one I can say that
but that's not reality because I
basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because they cannot say no you need
to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsize
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize Hey Kevin
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today if you're
feeling lost watch this video to change
your future enjoy
rule number two is develop an
exceptional attitude with Bob Proctor
how would you like a guaranteed 100
guaranteed way of winning
at anything in life
well you know I can give it to you
and it's all wrapped up in a word Earl
Nightingale said it was the most
important word in the English language
or any other language as far as that
goes and its attitude
General I don't think most people really
understand what attitude is
now I have learned it and I've learned
it well
because I had one of the greatest
teachers in the world teach it to me and
that was the real name Gail I spent five
years working with him it was just a
wonderful experience
I'm going to put a drawing up here and I
want you to pay real close attention to
this drawing
we'll let this drawing represent you
now the big part of the drawing
is your mind
and the bottom part of course is the
body but we're going to take the mind
and we're going to break it into two
parts
we'll say the top half is the conscious
mind
and the bottom half is the subconscious
mind
and of course the instrument that does
all the work
is the body
attitude takes in all three parts now
let's really get into this and pay
attention if you watch this a thousand
times I guarantee you your attitude will
always be pretty good and that's really
what you want
so let's stop and think
there is an absolute power flowing to
and through us this power can be
photographed it's pure unadulterated
spirit it's flowing into our conscious
mind and we create thoughts we let her
create them or we can pick them up from
outside sources I choose to pick my own
choose my own thoughts now when you
entertain thoughts
you do two things with them
you impress them upon your subconscious
but you also send those thoughts out
into the world
that's right you can pick up another
person's thoughts
and the thoughts that you impress
turn into feelings
now those feelings are not only
affecting the body they're expressed out
into the world so you send your feelings
out into the world if another person is
feeling bad and you're with them you'll
pick it up
now what's impressed upon the body is
expressed the body moves into action
and produces the results
so let's take a look here
one two three your thought is your
position is bearing as indicating
thoughts feelings and actions it's not
just the way you think there's not just
the way you feel it's not just the way
you act it's the composite of all three
your thoughts cause your feelings your
feelings are expressed in actions and
that side expression that dictates
results do you know your attitude
determines what you attract to you I
don't care what it's about
you can blame other people you can blame
conditions or circumstance you can blame
the government
it won't do you any good until you fully
understand that your life is a
reflection of your attitude
you're going to have a problem
pick the right attitude choose good
thoughts turn them into good feelings
have good actions and you're going to
express that that's what the world will
send back to you attitude is our
position or bearing dedicating thoughts
feelings and action watch this often and
then compare it in life
you'll find out it works like an
adulterated magic rule number three is
learn from suffering with Tom bilyu why
should I take steps to learn from my own
suffering
when it is so unpleasant
this one is very easy to answer and the
reason that you want to
learn from your suffering is because if
you don't you're going to repeat your
suffering
and if it is unpleasant the first time
you can imagine how deeply unpleasant it
gets over time because let me tell you
how the human mind works
anything that you do a lot becomes
easier and it goes into What's called
the default mode Network the default
mode network is the part of the brain
that you access when you're daydreaming
or when you're driving to work and you
get there and all of a sudden you're
like whoa how did I get here I wasn't
even paying attention and the way that
you get there is because that's
something that you've done repetitively
it's been it's it's actually been
hardwired it's been made more
calorically efficient so the brain
actually wraps these myelin sheaths
around these connection points so that
the impulses travel more efficiently
and then by moving it into the default
mode Network by hardwiring it now it
becomes literally the default thing that
you think so if you repeat that
suffering and you make the same mistakes
over and over and over and you keep
doing the things that lead to your
suffering then that suffering becomes
the easiest thing to do versus learning
from your suffering we're in a very
finite period of time you're going to
have to stare very nakedly at it you're
going to have to lean into it you're
going to have to take responsibility
even if it truly is somebody or
something else's fault by giving the
power over to them you will end up in
that Loop where you're just being
victimized over and over and over not
realizing that you can take control of
that situation and get out of that
victimization pattern because you have
the agency to change something and get a
different result and once you change
something and start getting a different
result now you're putting that skill set
to use that you got by reflecting on
where you went wrong what you could
control again even when you truly have
been victimized
you do not have to play the victim and
you certainly don't have to repeat that
pattern so by taking this very finite
time looking very concretely at what the
exact problem is what you could have
done differently taking that
responsibility taking that power back
that's really what you're doing when
you're taking responsibility you're
taking the power
now when you have the power
you're able to make a choice in the
future that brings you better results
and therefore you don't end up living in
that Loop of repeating that problem and
in avoiding the repeating of the problem
and repeating the suffering you don't
get that hard wiring in your brain that
pattern does not go to the default mode
Network and therefore it isn't the
easiest thing for you to think and once
you break that pattern and let those old
things atrophy by taking the time to
actually figure out what you need to
change
now you can create forward momentum in
your life and now figuring out what you
need to do to change now acquiring new
skills those are the things that get
moved to the default mode Network and
now suddenly when you encounter a
problem the solution is the thing that
comes to your mind because you've
reinforced that over and over and over
you constantly are claiming your power
you are constantly looking at the things
that you need to do differently in order
to get a different result and you are
constantly executing against that and
that becomes that Loop and I can't tell
you how much in the beginning when I
started my growth mindset Journey it was
oh God it took so much time and energy
to stop feeling sorry for myself to stop
feeling like a victim to even remember
to think about the fact that I could do
something differently that I could take
responsibility
but as I started doing that and got
these tremendous results out of my life
and started doing it more and more and
then it became my default answer the
very thing that I would click into as
soon as I encountered a problem it was
like word if I take responsibility for
this if I claim back my power now I'm
going to be able to turn this into a
skill set and once I have a skill set
then I can do things that other people
can't do and I can change my life
and
because that reinforces through so much
positivity and it's so useful and so
effective it will hardwire itself and
once you're there you are well on your
way to winning also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is experiment with Joe
dispenza uh what are some of in the
formula for example the things that you
teach to help take this incredible
knowledge and put it into practice I
think the most important part is to
experiment to be curious to really see
you know most people they respond to
their outer environment in their outer
environment is really controlling the
way they think and feel and I say David
why are you upset today it's because of
that personal circumstance what you're
really saying is that some person or
circumstance is actually controlling the
way I feel and the way I think well most
of the time our response to the
environment because of the stress
hormones actually weakens the organism
that goes a step further though when you
think about your problems you produce
the same stress response as if it was
happening your body's so objective it's
believe it's it's living in that
environmental State and it's that
constant attack and that response uh
from the environment that begins to down
regulate genes and weaken the immune
system so the fundamental question is if
you can turn on the stress response by
thought alone the long-term effects of
those chemicals push the genetic buttons
that create disease then that means our
thoughts can make us sick so then if our
thoughts can make us sick is it possible
that our thoughts can make us well so
when a person is less responsive less
than a victim to their environment to
their environment is no longer
controlling the way they think and feel
then the next fundamental question is if
I change the way I think and feel should
it change my environment now that's
going from a victim in your life to
being a creator of your life and that's
the experiment and everybody should
believe that they are the creator of
their life we teach people some basic
tools the formula really is about 10
years of research that we were able to
say you could actually change your brain
waves and create more order in your
brain the the dissonance and incoherence
that's created when we're under stress
really causes the brain to
compartmentalize and fire out of order
and so we've demystified the process
after looking of at thousands of scans
to be able to say you could actually
make your brain work better and you can
do that in a very short amount of time
so in order to create a new future
to change something in your life nothing
changes in your life until you change
that's that's the story right so then
the question is okay is in order for me
to create something new I'm going to
have to combine a clear intention that's
a function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at and you got to combine that
with an elevated emotion and that means
then you can't wait for your healing to
feel grateful you can't wait for your
new relationship to feel love you can't
wait for your wealth to feel abundance
you know that's that's the old model of
reality of cause and effect in fact
we're going to teach people actually how
to feel the emotion before it happens
and when you combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order it
turns out that's a skill too that you
can practice so then when you combine
those two elements so that clear
intention with the elevated emotion and
you can sustain that for a period of
time the coherence in the brain the
coherence and the Heart actually act
like a Wi-Fi signal you're starting to
put out a Broadband spectrum of
frequency and energy that causes you to
feel connected to something and now
you're no longer trying to get something
done or waiting for something in your
outer World to Change to take away the
emptiness or lack you're feeling because
you don't have the experience yet if
people can actually feel the feelings of
the emotions before the experience
happens they wouldn't be looking for it
because they would feel like it already
happened right so they teach people how
to sustain these states and if they can
the side effect of that is that you
start seeing synchronicities in your
life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or Force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or compete for it that's that's
when we're matter trying to change
matter when you synchronize your energy
to a possibility in your life and you
start seeing those synchronicities in
your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
just going to start paying attention to
what you've been doing and do more of it
and you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you rule number five is take a break
with Brian Tracy today I want to talk to
you about how to transform your life by
taking a break at the right time
sometimes the best thing that you can do
is nothing at all
and what I mean by that is instead of
immediately acting or responding to
something taking a breath or a minute to
pause and to think can transform your
life and help incorporate more
mindfulness into your day-to-day life
that for that reason you'll make fewer
mistakes you'll get more done faster and
you won't have to go back and repeat it
it's easy to get caught up in the world
around us with the seemingly endless
task lists and projects to be completed
daily we have many conversations make
many decisions and keep moving forward
this causes us to feel stressed and
overwhelmed and rarely leaves even a
moment to absorb what's really going on
this can ultimately lead to feeling
disconnected and out of control
however taking time to pause to take a
break your thoughts your actions your
speech Etc is an incredibly helpful tool
to re-centering yourself regaining
control and getting back on track
stronger and better than ever
here are three times to take a break in
your life and help you to re-center to
accomplish all of your goals
I personally use these tools in my own
life to help me accomplish goals and
I've seen how much they have helped and
transformed the lives of others as well
the first time to take a break is to
pause before responding
there's a reason why we have two ears
and one mouth as we should spend more
time listening than we do speaking
you notice when someone is actually
listening and paying attention to what
you are saying rather than just waiting
for you to be finished so that they can
jump in
when we are just waiting for our turn to
talk we don't pay attention to what the
other person is saying we don't absorb
what the other person is meaning we just
want it to be quick to provide our own
input however if we aren't listening and
understanding what is being said we may
not be providing useful insights with
our response this can lead to
miscommunication misunderstanding and a
waste of everyone's time it's
astonishing throughout history how a
miscomprehension of a word or phrase or
something that someone said or didn't
say has transformed the entire situation
the next time you have a conversation
really listen and absorb what the other
person is saying
reflect on their words and be conscious
of what they are trying to convey to you
this is called active listening
consider these questions
why are they telling you this
what kind of response are they looking
for to receive from you
are they worried about your reaction
taking a pause before you respond and
considering your answers to those
questions will give you time to
formulate a Mindful and helpful response
rather a better quick reaction
the second time to take a break is to do
so before making a big decision
we all get caught up in the excitement
and anxiety associated with making a big
decision this can cause us to lose sight
of the bigger picture
and while spontaneity and risk-taking
can be useful in some decision making
greatness does not come from
impulsiveness or acting on a whim
that is why it is so important to give
yourself a moment to pause and to
reflect on the situation
this allows you to ensure that you are
making a decision with a sound mind
rather than reacting with emotion
when you have a big decision to make
take a pause and then think through the
following questions
have you done the necessary research on
the choices
have you considered all possible
outcomes are you comfortable with the
risk that you're willing to take
the third time to take a break is after
a decision has been made or a
conversation always had to reflect on
any lessons to learn
after having had an important
conversation or having made a
transformative decision we usually find
ourselves feeling relieved
the pressure of the situation has been
eased and we can move on with our lives
right not quite without taking a moment
to pause and consider the implications
of the situation we can short-circuit
our ability to grow
that's why it's very important to take a
moment to reflect on our decisions and
conversations after they've been had
ask yourself these questions
what did you learn
how did this make you feel
what can you apply to your next decision
or a conversation that can make it
better
these reflective moments following an
important decision or conversation are
opportunities for growth as a person and
as a leader
utilize them to continue your journey to
achieving your goals and becoming the
best version of yourself that you can
possibly be
I promise that if you follow these steps
and start taking a more time to consider
you will see your life start to
transform for the better
and if you're looking for a guide to
help you to optimize your success and
achieve your goals check out my personal
development guide it will help you to
take time off to identify areas of
opportunity and to evaluate your goals
effectively
this powerful personal development guide
will act as a daily tool to help you to
reach your goals faster and rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is develop mental
toughness with Eric Thomas everybody
wants to be a b Shaw until the time
just being real this
this is what you're going to have to do
to go to beast mode in this industry
because here's what I'm going to tell
you when you go beast mode they're going
to be certain things that happen for you
don't happen for other people
let me tell you I had to go beast mode
we had to do a whole year of marketing
I've never done that before
[Music]
never done I've never taken a year to do
nothing
we had to market for an entire year
exhausting so I had to travel everywhere
to do podcasts so I didn't want to do it
because I had been traveling since I was
19. and I promised my wife when we hit
50 I wouldn't travel as much so I'm
already traveling as a speaker so she
didn't want me traveling as a speaker
and doing free podcasts
does that make sense now I gotta go tell
my wife I'm sorry but I gotta go do
podcasts so everybody wants to be at
Beast until it's time to do what bees do
if you become a beast in this industry
nothing or no one will stop you the
reason why a lot of you are not where
you should be is because you're not in
beast mode
and you need to go be small how many of
y'all ready to get what y'all desire let
me see how many of y'all deserve to get
what you desire come on how many of your
families desire to get it all right so
once we go after this slide we not
returning we're going beast mode
y'all ready come on y'all ready all
right let's get ready to take notes
real beasts have mental toughness
this is where most let me
most people are divided mental toughness
is the ability to resist to manage
overcome doubt overcome worries overcome
concerns overcome circumstances that
prevent most people from succeeding or
performing under pressure
[Music]
I want you to understand every every
human being that is not successful
versus every human being that's
successful the only difference between
them is mental toughness one group when
they come up against trials and
tribulations they shrink
one group of people when they come up
against a recession they shrink
[Music]
you know I started this book
during covet
you know you know I started the process
of this book doing covert and let me
tell you why mental toughness
when Kobe hit I didn't look at covert
and go whoa it's me
when Kobe hit I went oh I got time now
I'm about to be off the road
oh I ain't gotta travel no more
I can write a book and if I sell a
million copies of this book I can make
about 14 15 million without having to do
anything but get passive income so while
everybody is complaining about Kobe
here's the chance for me to spend some
time doing something I've never had time
to do and here's a time to go harder on
my career and study more than I've ever
studied
Mitchell toughness say it with me one
two three
one two three
one two three
this is what you're gonna need to get to
the next level so why every everybody
was crying and complaining I was getting
up working out for at least an hour hour
and a half a day because I didn't want
to catch coffee I did more vitamin C I
should have opened up the vibe I should
have opened up a vitamin C tablet
company I have more vitamin C I ever had
in my life
I bought a Peloton bike I bought a
peloton's treadmill I bought my wife an
elliptical we went to work in Covey you
you know what I never got covet once in
the whole time frame Kobe I never I
never got coveted I made up in my mind
let's Okay how do you get coveted okay
people I stay away from people
[Music]
no can I be honest with you guys I had
less than 100 members in my church Kobe
hit the month before I bought fancy
cameras to put in my church
we had 50 000 people watching service
during covet we only had 100 people in
church before that we went to a mega
church and went and made over seven
figures I started hiring full-time staff
we blew up in Kobe why
weak-minded people no disrespect they
Buckle Undercovers they complained
during Copans they look for every excuse
during covet but mentally tough people
we saw the storm and we pulled on our
surfboard and we begin to surf on the
ways that drown most people
came out with a New York Times best
during covet
that's what beast mode is beast mode is
I will not stop
stop I
I quit when it gets hard beast mode is I
will not complain I will not worry I
will not fret I will find a way when
there is no way I will make a door when
there is no door I will create a window
when there is no window I will create
Finance when there is no Finance I will
find an opportunity when it doesn't
exist but I will not be defeated
cause I know what my desires are and I
know what I deserve
the Dallas Uber driver I
know so as somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling
and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back
and how much pain people feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet they're spending all of their
time and energy arguing against what
they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and Latino men to do the
same in acting and I'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
Dallas right yeah the guy's 25 and so I
I go you know the game is in New York
and L.A I mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in Dallas
but why are you not in La why are you
not in New York and he's like you're
right you're right you're right I need
to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves you need
that instinct for meaning too so and we
should get this real straight why do you
need it well you need it because life is
really really difficult right I mean
people have a rough time of it there's
plenty of suffering in life and everyone
is going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lifes they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see this skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the D default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've taken a very vicious turn into
the darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning you
wanted to be a professional baseball
player is that right yeah but then you
got an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big leagues or did
you play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways you aren't going to be in The
Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me it certainly didn't seem like it
at the time but it got me out of that
and into something like what we're
talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just talking before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were there career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is
when the first one ends it doesn't
happen whether that be a relationship it
could be your marriage it ends it was a
dream right or a business venture or a
sport I went into a pretty good
depression and uh and how old were you
at the time 21 22 and I ended up you
know it's because people always see the
after like the house or whatever houses
or whatever the material things are but
I ended up bad man I ended up to press I
ended up moving back at home with my
parents I was living in the city I
remember I was living in this sleeping
with the same bed I grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters I was
like going back in time like six years
on back where I was totally unemployed
and uh couldn't find work didn't have
the motivation to get up and find a job
just sort of eating out of their fridge
and laying around all day so that's
where I was many many years ago after
baseball end when you realize things in
your life happen for you truly
especially in hindsight everybody knows
it in hindsight right if you look back
at any disaster tragedy most people look
back five ten years they think that
happened for me that was actually a good
thing and so I was unemployed I couldn't
find a job and my old man my dad was the
best dad role model he could ever have
in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylett I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh dude yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go look literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like McKinley is a massive
campus full of children that have been
displaced from their homes that live in
individual like Cottages like a foster
care facility massive though really yep
all boys it's in San Dimas here and um
wow it just altered my life man because
I I'd been an athlete had a huge ego had
that mask I wanted to compete I wanted
to win I wanted attention I wanted
recognition first time literally in my
life I went well I I love helping people
I love making a difference and my boys
were just come from horrendous
situations and so just I always say this
all the time and I have those eyes too
you have them I think sometimes kids who
grow up with some dysfunction they just
have different eyes yeah they just have
these eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they just like man love me believe in me
you know care about me and I had those
eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just
went wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little that I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people ultimately I really
believe that the probably the most I
don't know the most sacred thing in our
lives that we can give another human
being besides our love is our labor you
think about it your labor is your energy
it's your time it's your emotion it's
your intellect it's your spirit to some
extent and if you can find a way where
what you do for a living activates that
sense of what you're made for then work
is not work whether you're being Fiji or
whether you be in a an environment that
might be seen less exciting and
promising in the moment trust me I
worked in plenty of those too but with
the same level of excitement and passion
because I found what turns me on that
makes me feel alive makes me feel like
I'm doing something that's worthwhile
and on Labor Day I think a lot of people
it's just a holiday to get away and take
time off of Labor uh and my hope is to
trigger you to think about how could you
turn your labor into your love I think
it was Mark Twain has said when your
vocation becomes your vacation that's
when life becomes truly magnificent and
I'm privileged enough to have that but I
pursued it and one of the secrets that I
found and I know you know this in your
soul is that we all know if you're going
to be masterful at something you don't
show up you know as the best in the
world at something you don't show up in
environments that you want to be in you
get there because you did things for
thousands and thousands of hours most of
you know the concept of Mastery taking
ten thousand hours that's an arbitrary
number but I'm sure you've heard about
you want to get really good at something
it's 10 000 hours because when you do
something enough with enough intensity
enough intention to constantly get
better when your labor is your love and
where your labor is something you have
to always get better at then usually
what happens is you get these insights
that allow you to serve more but I also
think that labor you know we're talking
about this weekend what makes people
fulfilled by their labor is is their
motives for it if your motive is just to
make money or just to pay your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money the most fulfilled human
beings in my experience and and I've had
the privilege of working with literally
four million people from 125 countries
now around the world the people that are
most alive regardless of the economics
are people that have found something
that they really feel the motive is more
than just themselves you know we all
know what it feels like when you're
trying to do for something for someone
you love and you're not doing it as a
trade you're not trying to get something
back you're just doing it because it's
What You're Made for and I always tell
people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because life supports whatever else
supports life if you're part of life and
you're trying to do something that's
going to make your life better I think
the universe God whatever proper term
for you whatever your belief system is
you know infinite intelligence gets
connected to you and it gives you
insights but I think if you're trying to
serve more than yourself more life than
just you when things support more of
life more of Life shows up to support
you and that might sound kind of Airy
fairy but it's my experience you know
when you're trying to support your
family when suddenly I had four kids
three of them overnight my life changed
my intellect change my abilities change
because I was trying to serve something
more than just me uh when I started
really focusing how to serve a community
and then a country and then Humanity
with corny as it may sound you get
insights you won't get when you're just
trying to somehow you know make your
labor happen or get the job done so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people I think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at Labor as work they look at as why
should I have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say Tony that's all wonderful you're in
Fiji and you do what you love and I
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture I'm not coming
from that place I've come from the
places saying you can discover something
that you're really passionate about but
in order to do it you got to get out of
the story of what you can't do and
you've got to put yourself on the line
your challenges don't only make you
stronger they allow you to serve better
I think the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
they put in your way allow you to have a
a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor they're built to serve
you are built to serve when you can
connect the challenge that you're going
through as something that's then going
to inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to it just being about me
getting stronger I find a lot of times
me getting stronger is not enough it's
not enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road quarter of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges and making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this is a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop
let's go to Kansas City and see what
happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who's
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash
uh we're we're next so we're probably
gonna get some crazy noise we have to
talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
um maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time you know like
that stuff happens all the time and look
we're next you guys can see it says
car wash or next depending on how long
that guy ahead of us takes you might you
might see it in this video I dealt with
a lot of those mindset issues those lack
of belief issues those worthiness issues
and I I battled them and I've been
through them and
yeah have a few lessons to share
and over the years of me trialing and
failing and you know 20 plus years of
doing this
my hope is to make the path a little bit
easier for you so that you don't have to
struggle as much as I did and the path
can be a little bit sooner a little bit
faster a little bit less painful right
but I've never been through anything
really physical you know I've broken my
toe
I remember breaking my toe
uh and then going for a run and I was
doing Instagram live at the times like a
light run fast Jog and I like my toe was
hurting so much and I just kept powering
through I didn't later realize I broke
my toe but that's not really anything
major right you know if somebody's going
through something physical and major
it's like you broke your toe come on
it's not a big deal and so I never felt
like I could
serve or push people who
had a physical limitation
I had a physical kind of injury because
I'd never gone through and I don't feel
right pushing people on things that I
haven't experienced in some form myself
right
so here I am 2009 2019 now I break my
neck now I'm having concussion I'm in
more pain I've ever been in my life
concussion if you haven't been through
it is just devastating because it's not
just the physical pain of not being able
to move your body and you know neck and
potentially having spinal surgery which
is crazy scary but also not being able
to think clearly first for me I I value
that a lot like I love thinking you know
I love problem solving and not being
able to think clearly and just be a
vegetable on the couch all day was was
devastating so getting through that and
then deciding I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
going
I'm gonna at least try for the next stop
in Kansas City why
because if I can get through this
yes it's a challenge that will teach me
and make me stronger and I have a lesson
that I can learn from it but
if I can get through this then hopefully
can serve as an inspiration for other
people who are going through something
physical as well but it's not just a
mindset issue but they have physical
limitations
you know the first couple the first
night in the hospital I was you know a
train wreck then I came home and
uh to our Airbnb they let me out of the
hospital and I remember two specific
Moments One
trying to get into the car
so we're at the hospital I get
discharged I'm excited to go home fresh
air oh my gosh it's amazing and I have
this neck brace on I can't move I'm very
low flexibility and I'm now the
passenger I'm not allowed to drive
because I can't turn my head so Nina has
to Nina has to drive and I'm in the
parking lot of the hospital
and
I'm trying to get into the passenger
side I'm in the passenger seat right now
in my car I'm trying to get into the
passenger side of the car and I can't
and it hurts too much and I get to the
point where I have one foot in the car
and one foot out of the car
and it's a Suburban since this is giant
step up to get in
and I remember being so
I was in so much pain
that I couldn't go forward into the car
I didn't have the strength and every
time I lift it off it it killed
everything in my body the whole like all
my back up into my neck everything was
in massive pain but I also couldn't get
back down
because that was hurting too much too so
I was in I was stuck in this limbo if I
can't go forward I can't go back
[Music]
Nina's trying to you know push me up to
get me in and I remember just crying
I'm in the parking lot of the oh we're
going in the car wash I'm in the parking
lot I'm gonna have to talk louder I'm in
the parking lot
of the hospital and I'm crying
out of frustration and I can't remember
the last time I was that frustrated that
I just broke down and cried and I I
didn't know what to do next everything
hurt I can't move forward I can't move
backwards I'm just overwhelmed by pain
and frustration and I'm crying in the
parking lot of the hospital
eventually Nina
just pushes me in
one hand on each butt cheek and like in
you go and I got it and it hurt but but
then I was in
and that was just
an overwhelming moment
and then I remember that night
here we go car wash
that night
uh it was I mean I can't sleep it's
terrible i've got you know neck brace on
I'm not used to sleeping with it I'm in
massive pain and it's it's three in the
morning
and I have to go to the bathroom
and so I'm sitting I I can get myself to
sit up they taught me in the hospital
how to push yourself from
um
lying down to
to sitting up oh look here comes look at
the foam look at that guys how to go
from lying down to sitting up without
hurting yourself too much like
minimizing the pain as much as possible
so they taught me how to do that
so three in the morning I have to go to
the bathroom I get up uh I push myself
into the seating position
I'm starting to feel dizzy I have a
concussion right I'm starting to feel
dizzy I can't see anything because it's
really dark and
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
fall over
how I got the concussion was I fainted I
fainted my head on the wall and then
cracked my my the back of my neck open
I'm worried that if I stand up I might
faint and I might fall over again
and I Nina's asleep next to me
look at this
were you sleeping on the floor Nina's
joining in no you're on the bed we're on
the floor
she was afraid she's gonna wake me up I
mean bless Nina's Hearts I mean she had
no sleep during this whole time too
right so she's asleep it's three in the
morning and I and I
I don't want to wake her up one because
I feel bad for her because she hasn't
slept at all but also I feel helpless I
feel so helpless
that I mean all this pain and I can't
even go I can't even go to the bathroom
by myself like I need help to go to the
bathroom I felt so helpless and I said
it's it's not worth it for me to get up
and and potentially like if I fall
that's that's that's no bueno right I'm
back to the hospital probably if I fall
so I wake up Nina and I mean it may not
seem like a big deal but it it felt like
a big deal like I felt just helpless
and so I had yeah I woke her up she
helped me go to the bathroom and you
know I did my business and went back to
sleep but
those two moments in particular were the
most painful moments of that whole
experience
it's the best uh
and and the thing that got me through it
the thing that gave me the motivation
was that
hopefully somebody else who's going
through some kind of painful moment
right now
we'll be able to resonate with this and
be inspired by this whether it's
actually true or not it was a story that
I was telling myself I told myself
somebody's going to be inspired by this
and I still made videos and my next
round of videos I couldn't do the whole
thing so Nina did some of it I did some
of it
um and I'm sitting there I'm I'm now
overweight because I'm uh you know I
haven't been able to work out
um I've been eaten as clean as I was
normally I got a giant scab if you look
at some of those old videos I had this
huge scab on my forehead again
normally like oh my gosh I got this
giant scab on my you might be worried
about a little pimple look at this giant
scab coming down my forehead it looked
like Harry Potter the thing that gets me
through it is
other people
who have some kind of issue like they're
having a bad hair day or a pimple on
their face might be inspired by this to
go and take action what Nina has a
paintball whatever you want to show
everybody your pimple on your forehead
again whether it's true or not it was a
story that I was telling myself that
somebody else is going to be inspired by
this and it's going to allow them to go
and do their thing
um now fast forward
make the videos we release the videos a
lot of people were inspired by a lot of
people did message me DM me email me
tell me in future interviews you know I
was I was telling myself I couldn't do
this because of X because I had a
headache
and here you are doing your videos with
a concussion
giant Scout on your face neck brace in
massive pain breaking your neck and I
told myself what I have no excuse I'm
gonna go do my thing because Evan did
his thing
but again whether it was true or not
the thing that got me to get through the
challenge in a way that I'm proud of
myself for
was the connection to service
that it's not just here to make me
stronger which it did made me incredibly
like I can't believe I did that that guy
is still in me that I could go and do
that again hopefully they'll break my
neck again but I could do that
It Made Me Stronger but even more
valuable
is me feeling like this is gonna mean
something to somebody else so whatever
challenge you're going through
understand that yes you know your
purpose culture and your pain
this will make you a better person
but the thing that will help you get
through it at least to my experience is
connecting to somebody else
that there are tons of people out there
who are also struggling with the same
thing that you are struggling with right
now and when you get through it your
story will be an inspiration for them
your journey through it
will motivate them to have the courage
to show up for their lives as well and
when you can actually connect it to
service I think everything is better you
are built to serve we made it through
the car wash
[Laughter]
good job Nina hopefully that uh you
heard all that stuff and it was valuable
and life-changing and if not I love you
anyway
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want the advice to remember when times
get tough check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the key is to tie yourself Worth
to the effort to try and if you do that
well you'll win Beyond Your Wildest
imaginations so let's use me as an
example look at this video two minutes
before getting on and making this video
I'm nervous